Matt, what are some of the most popular visualizations that you see on Poly?
>> yeah, I think just kind of like the most often used ones because they're so
familiar and also because, you know, they're kind of the classics.
We see a lot of line charts, bar charts and
scatter charts and then a lot of histograms.
But it also depends a lot on the user.
Like certain users will only make bubble charts, or only make,
you know, hit maps.
so, if you scroll through our feed,
you can see a lot of different types of graphs.
But those are the, the most often made types.
>> Okay.
And other any unconventional chart types that you see?
>> Yeah. So one fun thing about Plotley is
you can kind of invent your own chart types if you like to.
We've tried to make it a really flexible environment for being able
to use different languages or different programs to be able to draw your graphs.
So we don't natively support maps, for example.
But people have made maps using different packages from Python or R.
People have made network visualizations, which we don't natively support,
but Someone has made a couple of those using a language called Julia.
And then we've also seen people make sort of
just their own out of the box data visualizations.
That mimic some type of event that they'd like to show a visualization of.
That doesn't even necessarily have a name with a graph type.
>> Okay.